sur abdelmajid tebboune à l'occasion de
la soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale de son débat
général au nom de dieu clément et
miséricordieux
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
générale monsieur le secrétaire général
majesté altesse mesdames et messieurs
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
excellences mesdames et messieurs c'est
un honneur pour moi que de m'adresser à
cette auguste assemblée au nom d'une
nouvelle algérie une algérie qui
souhaite construire un système
démocratique répondant aux aspirations
de son peuple le peuple algérien a en
effet offert le plus bel exemple de
défense des valeurs de liberté et de
justice
qu'il me soit permis d'exprimer tout
d'abord mes voeux de plein succès à son
excellence monsieur volkan bosquier
président de la soixante quinzième
session de l'assemblée générale
succédant ainsi à son excellence
monsieur mohamed tijani bandits dont
nous saluons la présidence réussie de la
saison précédente
je saisis également cette occasion pour
remercier le secrétaire général des
nations unies monsieur antonio guterres
esch de ses efforts inlassables notre
organisation a été fondée à la suite
d'une épouvantable tragédie humaine son
rôle et sa performance ont connu des
succès ainsi que des échecs face à des
défis internationaux toujours plus
nombreux et qui ont dévoilé de multiples
failles dans le système international
surtout dans les circonstances
sanitaires actuelles
monsieur le président nous avons besoin
d'une organisation des nations unies qui
soit forte
nous soulignons la nécessité de faire
avancer le dossier de la réforme globale
de notre organisation afin d'améliorer
sa performance et promouvoir son
efficacité l'algérie souligne à ce sujet
son attachement à la position de l'union
africaine conformément au consensus des
eaux lui ni et la déclaration de syrte
nous appelons de nos voeux les
négociations gouvernementales ou
intergouvernementales sur la
représentation équitable au conseil de
sécurité et l'augmentation du nombre de
ses membres en plus d'autres sujets
connexes et ce dans le but de parvenir à
des solutions rapides
il est à 58 ans mon pays devenait membre
de l'organisation des nations unies
depuis il n'a eu de cesse de défendre la
paix et la sécurité internationales en
fondant sa politique étrangère sur les
valeurs de règlement pacifique des
différends la non-ingérence dans les
affaires internes des états le respect
de la souverainté et de l'unité des
états ainsi que du droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes et de leurs
richesses
nous sommes aujourd'hui fiers de nos
réalisations qui ont mis en exergue la
centralité de la médiation diplomatique
algérienne dans le règlement d'un grand
nombre de crises contentieuses et de
conflits régionaux et internationaux
notre diplomatie est toujours mobilisée
au service de cet objectif non
là et ce en mettant l'accent sur les
résolutions de l'onu et de la légitimité
internationale
partant de cette approche l'algérie a
oeuvré et oeuvrent toujours au
rapprochement entre les différentes
parties libyennes
nous appelons le peuple libyen frère à
s'engager dans un processus politique
sous les auspices des nations unies afin
de sortir de cette crise et répondant
ainsi à la volonté du peuple libyen et
refusant toute intervention étrangère
qui porterait atteinte à la souveraineté
de la libye l'algérie se félicite des
deux récentes déclarations de cessez le
feu et nous appelons les parties
concernées à traduire les actes traduire
les paroles en actes au plus tôt mon
pays suit de près la situation sensible
qui prévaut au mallié ce pays voisin et
frère
nous espérons et attendons le retour
rapide à l'ordre constitutionnel par le
biais d'une transition consensuelle
consacrant la volonté du peuple malien
et ses aspirations
quant à la sécurité la stabilité et le
développement
nous demeurons convaincus que l'accord
pour la paix et la réconciliation
nationale issue du processus d'alger
reste le contexte idoine pour faire face
aux défis de gouvernance politique et du
développement économique dans ce pays
frère avec soutien sincère et sage de la
part de la communauté internationale
pour ce qui est de la cause
palestinienne
celle ci reste pour l'algérie et pour
son peuple
une question sacrée et même la plus
grande des questions nous exprimons à
nouveau notre soutien indéfectible au
peuple palestinien et à sa lutte juste à
ses droits inaliénables qui ne peuvent
en aucun cas être un sujet de compromis
ou de marchandage nous appuyons son
droit à un état indépendant et souverain
avec pour capitale al qods al charif
la solution de ce conflit et nous en
sommes convaincus
la clé de la stabilité au proche orient
j'en viens à présent à la question du
sahara occidental
nous déplorons les obstacles qui se
posent
face à cette cause et à sa résolution
notamment l'arrêt des négociations entre
les deux parties au conflit et le retard
enregistré dans la désignation d'un
nouvel envoyé spécial des nations unies
au sahara occidental l'algérie appelle à
la mise en oeuvre des résolutions
pertinentes du conseil de sécurité
surtout pour ce qui est de
l'organisation du référendum
d'autodétermination au sahara occidental
qui ne cesse d'être reporté depuis plus
de 29 ans il est essentiel de désigner
un envoyé du secrétaire général et de
favoriser les négociations entre les
deux parties au conflit dans le but de
réaliser les espérances des peuples du
maghreb arabe et de l'afrique
quant au développement et l'intégration
monsieur le président
l'algérie renouvelle son engagement à
lutter contre le terrorisme et
l'extrémisme violent phénomène qui
constitue une grande menace à la paix la
sécurité et au développement dans le
monde
nous appelons à renforcer la coopération
internationale dans le domaine de la
lutte contre la corruption et le
blanchiment d'argent tout en veillant à
mettre en avant à mettre en oeuvre les
accords internationaux sur le sujet
surtout pour ce qui est de la
restitution aux populations des fonds
qui leur ont été
pillet partant de notre engagement
inébranlable à promouvoir et à
consolider la paix et la sécurité
internationales mon pays participent
activement aux efforts internationaux
dans le domaine du désarmement et de la
non-prolifération
l'algérie a souffert et souffre encore
des effets néfastes des tests nucléaires
qui ont été menées sur son territoire
lors de la colonisation
l'élimination totale des armes
nucléaires reste à nos yeux la seule
gare entier pour faire face aux dangers
qu'elle pose pour l'humanité l'algérie
accorde une grande importance aux
questions environnementales et
renouvelle son engagement vis-à-vis des
accords en la matière
nous déployons des efforts nationaux en
dépit de nos ressources limitées
notamment en incluant des aspects
environnementaux dans les politiques
publiques de l'état quant à la
responsabilité historique des pays
avancés vis-à-vis et de cette question
nous appelons à nouveau à renforcer le
soutien technique et financier apporté
aux pays en développement pour qu'ils
puissent faire face aux dangers
environnementaux qui les menacent
monsieur le président la femme
algérienne qui a pris part à la rive à
l'ab à la révolution de libération
nationale et à la lutte contre le
terrorisme poursuit aujourd'hui son rôle
fondamental dans le processus de
reconstruction nationale
il s'agit là d'un rôle exceptionnel est
primordial que l'algérie d'un eu de
cesse de favoriser sans oublier
l'importance accordée au rôle de la
jeunesse
et à sa participation à la vie publique
les circonstances difficiles imposées
par la pandémie de là que vit 19 n'ont
pas dissuadé l'algérie de poursuivre ses
efforts pour atteindre les objectifs de
développement durable
dans ce contexte mon pays finalise la
mise en place d'un cadre national pour
les indicateurs de progrès sur le chemin
parcouru vers les eaux d'aidé ou les
objectifs de développement durable
nous travaillons également à
l'intégration prochaine du programme de
développement durable à l'horizon 2030
dans les lois financières annuelles et
nous travaillons à la mise en place d'un
cadre juridique censée promouvoir et
faciliter le travail de toutes les
parties prenantes
monsieur le président
l'algérie avance à pas résolu pour
consacrer les piliers de la démocratie
de l'état de droit et de la justice
sociale
suite au changement démocratique
réalisé par le mouvement pacifique irak
un mouvement béni et civilisé qui a
abouti à l'organisation d'élections
présidentielles en décembre 2019
ces élections ont réaffirmé la
souveraineté du peuple algérien
la liberté de ses choix et de ses
décisions l'algérie durant les mois
écoulés et en des pieds de la situation
sanitaire éprouvante a franchi des
étapes essentielles dans le domaine des
réformes politiques économiques et
sociales des réformes censées construire
une algérie nouvelle forte sûre et
prospère dans ce contexte l'algérie
organisera à rhodes là en novembre
prochain un référendum sur le projet de
réforme de la constitution afin de
déterminer les fondements du régime
politique et démocratique qui garantit
la protection des droits et des libertés
et qui assure l'équilibré entre les
différents pouvoirs pour la moralisation
de la vie publique
le choix de cette date est un symbole
fort de notre loyauté et de notre
respect pour les sacrifices des martyrs
qui ont péri afin que nous vivions nous
et que vive l'algérie libre et
indépendante
finalement sur le président je voudrais
lancer un appel d'unités un appel de
solidarité pour venir à bout des
différents et pour faire face à ces
circonstances difficiles que traverse le
monde pour que nos pays et nos peuples
en sorte inde m
et afin que nous puissions poursuivre
notre chemin vers la stabilité la
sécurité et le développement
je vous remercie de votre attention je
vous salue et j'invoque sur vous la
miséricorde et la bénédiction divine en
t min guignera le neuf au nom de
l'assemblée générale
je remercie le président de la
république algérienne démocratique et
populaire pour son allocution
je donne maintenant la parole europe